PACIFIC.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN TELLS US ABOUT
A REINFORCED MESSAGE TO CHINA.
>> THE UNITED STATES MILITARY
HAS HAD A LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN
THE WESTERN PACIFIC TAKING ON
SMALLER ISLANDS.
>> A NOT SO VEILED WARNING TO
CHINA TO BUILD UP SECURITY IN
THE CHINA SEA.
SHOWING CHINA HAS PLACED NEW
SURFACE-TO-AIR MISSILES IN THE
SPRATLY, AND RECENTLY LANDED
NUCLEAR CAPABLE BOMBERS ON WOODY
ALLEN.
CHINA CALLS THE ACCUSATION
RIDICULOUS.
DEFENSE SECRETARY JIM MATTIS
WILL REASSURE ALLIES THAT THE
U.S. WILL NOT ALLOW CHINA TO
SPREAD ITS INFLUENCE UNCHECKED.
>> THERE HAD BEEN A PROMISE IN
2015 BY PRESIDENT XI WHERE HE
STATED THAT THEY WOULD NOT BE
MILITARY RISING THE ISLANDS.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT THEY HAVE DONE
EXACTLY THAT.
>> HAD A CHANGE OF COMMAND
CEREMONY IN HAWAII, THE OUTGOING
HEAD OF U.S. PACIFIC HORSES,
ADMIRAL HARRY HARRIS, ISSUED
ANOTHER WARNING.
>> CHINA REMAINS THE BIGGEST
LONG-TERM CHALLENGE, WITHOUT
FOCUS, INVOLVEMENT, AND
ENGAGEMENT BY THE UNITED STATES
AND OUR ALLIES AND PARTNERS,
THEY WILL REALIZE A GEMINI IN A
JOB.
WE SHOULD COOPERATE WITH BEIJING
WHERE WE CAN, BUT STAND READY TO
CONFRONT THEM WHEN WE MUST.
>> THE U.S. HAS STEPPED UP
OPERATIONS TO COUNTER CHINA,
SENDING NAVAL VESSELS NEAR THE
MAN-MADE ISLANDS THIS PAST
WEEKEND.
AND MATTIS ANNOUNCES HE HAS
CHANGED THE NAME OF PAY COMMS TO
END OPAQUE CALM, A SHOT ACROSS
THE BOW AT CHINA THAT FEELS
THREATENED BY WAY RIVAL INDIA.
IT SERVES AS A BACKDROP TO
POTENTIAL NORTH KOREA TALKS.
>> THE 27 YEAR HOLIDAY FROM
HISTORY IS OVER.